our guest today is a motion picture
director screenwriter dinosaur expert
writer of over 60 books both nonfiction
and fiction as well as children's and
comic books one of his books includes
the novelization of the empire strikes
back which was a national number one
bestseller for six weeks his films
include the mummy kiss countess
Dracula's orgy of blood and blood scarab
we welcome to the film courage studio
mr. Donald F glute welcome to welcome
yeah but there we go that was the first
I got activated by your voice yellow I
have that effect Donna let's say hi once
again down how are you supposed to know
thank you it's good to be on this cold a
ghetto happy the greatest thing about
you reading all those those titles their
care as I have all these films right
here in front of us Donald has been
generous enough to UM provide us a DVD
copy of his films and I'm very excited
about this I want to watch those
countless Dracula's orgy of blood I you
know this is fantastic stuff for for
those of you listening live you may want
to participate in today's show you can
reach us through twitter.com slash film
courage we will take your questions live
on the air at the end of the show once
again at film courage via Twitter and to
connect with us off the air hit us up at
film Kurds @ gmail.com well Donna let's
start out with where you grow up well I
grew up in Chicago was born in Texas but
I spent most of my younger years in
Chicago okay and I never really started
out wanting to be a writer or film I
think I wanted to make movies at a very
early age because I made amateur films i
started making amateur films when i was
nine and then it was bitten by the bug
but when I finally moved out to
California when I was 22 to go to USC
film school I really wasn't sure what I
wanted to do I my main goal I think was
not to work in a regular job you know
that's something I didn't like and
unfortunately or maybe fortunately I I
liked a lot of things and I was able to
do a lot of things I was a musician I
was you know I could write write fairly
well I could draw pictures I was a
pretty good artist as a kid and all
these things that you know yes I wanted
to do
mall and I i think my first professional
work really was as a musician I was a
rock musician for many years playing
bass guitar keyboards lead guitar and
things like that and when that fizzled
out we had a I was in a band called a
penny arcade that was produced by
michael nesmith who was then one of the
monkeys and we came so close to becoming
rockstars everything was going our way
then everything immediately collapse and
I didn't want to go back to playing and
nightclubs and things and I was able to
get some writing gigs writing i wrote a
a paperback book called true vampires of
history you know some monster magazine
articles and things like that and then I
realized I really did like writing and
that led to the working in the comic
book business i worked for Marvel and DC
and gold key and Charlton all the comic
book companies and and then when our
marvel thing collapsed the new editor
came in there and basically all of us on
the west coast got canned the next
logical step was going to TV animation
and so I wrote a lot of scripts for the
car saturday morning cartoon shows but I
was you know deep down really wanted to
make movies and that's what I'm doing
that which is kind of a step thing one
thing kind of led to another I'm curious
because you mentioned there that things
fell apart you know with the music
career that that things kind of came
tumbling down well my think so what did
you learn from that experience what did
you take from that that you now put into
your entertainment career that's allowed
you to swell you know the you have to
just move on you know you you just never
give up you know and I you know I was
getting older I didn't one I mean I
could have stayed in the music business
but I didn't want to be one of these
geezer rock bands you know I you know I
wanted to move on to other things and
the girls own scream at you when you
reach a certain age I i would guess and
and so and I've always been adventurous
I always wanted to pursue new things and
try new things and the tenth new things
and east thing was a challenge along the
way and but ultimately I wanted to make
movies and that's what I'm doing I mean
right now would you know for a while I
was spreading myself too thin i was
trying to do too many things rather than
focus on one particular area so while i
was having fun
you know doing hard work into writing
and doing music and other my friends who
were focusing on things you know like
then it's miran became the head of ilm
because that's what he did he did that
one thing and so I saw the handwriting
on the wall it said I've got to really
decide what career I want to have and I
decided it would be three Hussain
feature which is probably too too many
but I wanted to continue doing music on
the side and I'm still doing music mmm
but I wanted to be a writer and I also
want to be a filmmaker and I also
pursued my paleontology work also so
that's still probably too many things on
the plate but it's not as many as it
used to be and I was doing all kinds of
thing I'm doing magic I was doing you
know and I just get as I said spreading
myself too thin you have a site entitled
um I was a teenage movie maker we also
have a book and a DVD by the same name
what prompted you to begin your first
film I me did you have a support system
that encouraged your creativity no I
never did okay well my mother I gotta
get my mother credit she did support
everything I did she didn't encourage me
because I had a lot of crazy ideas when
I was a kid and you know that the other
kids in the neighborhood weren't doing
the other kids are out there playing
baseball and I was in the alley you know
with dresses the teenage werewolf you
know shooting movies and things um but
she never discouraged me you know she
never said don't do this you know but
she didn't say hey uh why don't you make
a werewolf movie everything like that uh
I started making movies not because I
wanted to be a filmmaker be but because
in those days you couldn't buy DVDs and
video tapes and you could even buy
movies with monsters in them or
dinosaurs or Dracula so I wanted we had
a 16-millimeter movie camera in our
family and we had a screen and a
projector and I wanted to be able to
show like a say a dinosaur movie anytime
I wanted to on that screen with that
projector and you couldn't get them
anywhere and it wasn't even legal to buy
them in those days and so I decided the
only way to do that was to make them
myself and that's all we started off it
was basically I wanted to show them not
make them and that kind then then the
course
everything kicked into high gear and I
realize I enjoyed the experience of
making films what is it though about
monster movies or or or you know science
fiction genre what is it that that how
did you get bitten by the bug well I
always loved well when I was a little
kid when I was very little kid I was
terrified anything like that I couldn't
watch a monster movie I had to sleep
with the light on in the bedroom you
know in the next room and I was I
couldn't go into these dark rides at
amusement parks because I would get
scared and then I read it then a movie
was coming out this I guess 1954 call a
creature from the black lagoon yes and I
didn't want to see that movie I was
videos gonna get scared and then I went
to see the movie and this isn't scary
this is cool I really like this and then
an article came out of Colliers magazine
very shortly after that and the article
was about the bud westmore makeup studio
Universal picture Universal
internationalist was called then and it
told how they made these monster suits
and they had a lot of color photos and
that's when I realized that hey these
things aren't really scary these are
these are neat you know and I at that
point this I became a fan but as far as
making movies like that its decides
being a fan and making the kinds of
movies i grew up with its commercial you
know it's it's hard to make independent
movies and sell them if it's if it's
about a guy dying of cancer or something
but if it's a horror film or a science
fiction movie or a say a martial arts
movie oh we go to the american film
market every year and the buyers coming
from all these foreign territories and
they want to see sex gore action that's
what they want to see they don't you
know and so it's it's hard to lose money
when you're making a good horror picture
they're always in vogue so it's
combination of being a fan of that sort
of thing and being able to make the
kinds of movies I I love this kid and
also you know the possibility making a
lot of money now we've had a question
come in through Twitter from mondo J so
let's go ahead and put this one out
there now what would films inspired you
and and and what are what are some of
your favorite directors my favorite
directors my my big inspirations as far
as direct
would be I guess too scant Stanley
Kubrick and Roger Corman Stanley Kubrick
just for his you know I've learned a lot
from watching Stanley Kubrick movies and
I've learned a lot from watching Roger
Corman was hard I can I can watch a
Roger Corman scene and I realize exactly
in the scene how he's saving money and
that's very important when you're making
long bunch of movies to save as much as
you can so those are I think are my two
big ones but of course I like a little
James Whale to made the original
Frankenstein Invisible Man of a big fan
of James Whale I'm a fan of a Spencer G
Bennett who directed cereals and B
Western so but I think Corman and
Kubrick were my two biggest influences
not that it shows in the movies because
we're you know we don't have the budgets
that either those two people had but at
least as far as theory and in how they
did what they did now you know after you
had mentioned you went to USC film
school after film school how did you
begin to carve out a career for yourself
well I didn't really when I I was
considered a rebellious or that there's
a book out called mythmaker it's about
George Lucas and I me they talk about me
a lot at book and I think one said when
one passage was something like Don Bluth
was the most disrupt disruptive force
ever to go through USC film school so I
got a lot of cramp from the faculty
there was almost expelled a couple times
not because of the quality the film cell
was making but because of the subject
matter I made a Superman movie and for
one of my classes and I got to think
addy in the class I said to the
instructor why did I get this D because
my film was better than most of the
other films that he said yes he wagged
his finger music but it was a Superman
movie and they actually called me they
had a meeting to decide whether and I
was going to stay in the department and
I had to take a half a year over because
of getting that marked in that class for
the Superman film and so I got very
bitter about moviemaking in general when
I left USC and immediately an
opportunity came up with this Mike nesma
thing and I went into the music business
um I when I was a teenager I really
wanted to be a rock star that was my one
of my main goals I used to watch Elvis
on the Dorsey's brothers TV show and
undie had Sullivan Show and The Beatles
when those girls screaming that's what I
wanted you know and so I figured hey
years old I can you know oh I answered
this ad at the Musicians Union bulletin
board I got in i played the bass i
auditioned and I got the gig and I did
that for several years after I got out
of school so I got a late start and then
when I when the music thing ended I I
thought well I don't have any
connections in the business I don't know
anybody in the business I'm not going to
get in because it was pretty much a
closed shop in those days still is and I
some writing opportunities that were
dumped in my lap and I and I went with
that so I just became basically a writer
for many many years but when you say
writing opportunity like how did these
opportunities dump themselves in your
life well I've always I've always been a
hustler I've always been a networker I
always go out you know I don't wait for
the phone to ring I'm always out there
you know I don't I don't just go through
the window the doorway of opportunity i
usually tend to build the door myself
person and go through it i I was in
Chicago when one day and uh oh I guess
was nineteen 66 or 67 and I was reading
a monster magazine called modern
monsters and I was I can do a better
magazine and this and then I noticed
that the address was the Playboy
building on Sunset Boulevard and so I
said when I when I when I went back
there or I call the guy ever called up
the publisher I said I can think I can
do a better job and then he hired me to
write a bunch of articles for it and
then with the next issue i was editing
it so you know just kind of going with
the flow when putting yourself in
positions where people are gonna know
who you are recognizing and recognize
your work and give you a chance you know
too many creative people don't do that
they sit home they rely on their agent
they wait for the phone to ring like
they get discouraged if they get a
rejection or something and I've always
had pretty thick skin and I've always a
set of always been pretty much of a
hustler and going out for it and
you know sometimes things don't work out
the way it was but you know you you go
after enough thing just throwin up the
arch of the dartboard wonder was going
to hit so that's your mindset you know
that you're proactive and you know that
in doing so you're going to make money
is that you that's where you're
confident yeah and a lot of times you
don't you know but you know you you know
someone's once said he who is not or she
who has not taken a risk has already
taken the biggest risk of all hmm you
know and I know people those careers of
ended quickly or because or never got
off the ground because they never you
know they never went after it and I I've
never been shy about contacting
publishers and editors and producers and
you know making phone calls and
introducing myself and now with the
internet with websites and things as
easy to just send a link to your website
they can see what you've done well let's
also talk about the balance of before
stuff starts paying for itself and and
working another job I mean if you
haven't made money with films what's
your advice on achieving that balance
because a lot of people are kind of
caught we've talked about it before
between those two worlds you know you're
you're doing great creative things but
you're still having to do some other a
little job on the side well the biggest
problem creative people have myself
included is we're not business people
hmm and if you're going to make movies
and things you gotta have either a
business sense because you've got to
raise that money if you don't raise that
money you have nothing you can have a
script you can have letters of intent
you can have headshots and all the sort
of thing but without the money to make
the movie you've got nothing and I see
people with the american film market up
walking around that Lobby the loews
hotel they're all directors and
producers they've got projects but they
don't have any money so they have no
projects really they have nothing and
the thing is if you don't have a
business sense you should do what I did
we just team up with the businessman I
have a business partner in Chicago with
our company and we grew up together so
we have a trust factor he knows he has
his only creative urges I think are in
having kids you know he but he doesn't
care what movies we he never read the
script he probably doesn't even though
the titles of most of our movies but I'm
just kidding there but but you've got it
know how to talk to people with the
money
and I'm sort of learning but that's not
where my passion is and so I have a hard
time doing that and it's john milius
once said to me John Milius 11 people
went to USC with he said you know
they're really succeed in this business
creatively you've got to be like twenty
percent or ten percent you know creative
in the rest used car salesman the other
percentage and is absolutely right most
of our investors don't even know what
the movies are making they don't have a
clue we don't let me make them limited
partners they don't read the scripts
because they don't know how to read a
script we don't let them make any week
they can make suggestions if we want but
we'd have to take any of them seriously
and we're not obligated to so I don't
then at your question but I'm really
curious when you say you know I at a
younger age in the earlier years when
you would get on the phone with with
whether it be publishers or producers
and you had you hadn't yet established
yourself you know you he didn't have the
credits go with it can you take us there
in terms of what was your your mindset
and you know why what does this put us
there I guess it went through your mind
it was arrogance oh i don't know i mean
i just was never shy about that sort of
thing but now it's a different world now
you know it you can't just call up a
film producers i had like to write a
script for your next movie or a
publisher thing i got this hot idea for
a book because now it's all agency and
everybody's worried about getting sued
because looking for a while there seemed
like every time Steven Spielberg made a
movie somebody was suing him saying he
stole their plot which he I'm sure he
didn't but you know when plots are
similar and you know I've come up with
plots that I mean I came up with a plot
for a novel that was very similar to
Jurassic Park you know but I mean there
was no connection error just it was just
a coincidence and so caught of producers
and editors and publishers are very
cautious now about accepting unsolicited
unsolicited material so when I started
out as much easier to do something like
that but once you get a reputation to
it's it's it's easier for people to take
it seriously if you make a phone call or
send an email now with everything you've
accomplished in your career
how much time and dedication has it
required you know for those listening I
mean you the amount of work that you've
that you've accomplished is amazing i
think it's 60 novels about 65 60 65
novel well thats includes non-fiction
books comics as well there's no comic
books or something else these are just
books books with you know covers and I
mean you know comic books and and and in
the films that you've made I mean you
know literally we could take up the
whole show listing all of your credits
so how many hours would you say over the
years goes into your standard work week
oh I it's hard to say I work all the
time and you know it's not you can't
just limit it to when you're behind that
word process or the typewriter because
if I go on a vacation vacation it's a
word I don't have my vocabulary I'm
working on the vacation I'm on the
airplane i'm thinking of plots what I'm
trying to get the sleep I'm thinking
applied to and when I'm out on a date
which unfortunately gets me into trouble
sometimes I lose track of the
conversation I'm having with the girl
because my mind is thinking of some plot
point I've got to work out in a story
and so I work I don't want to say 24 7
but pretty much all the time when I'm
driving a car i'm working out problems
in a script or something like that so
it's it's it's hard to really say that
but I mean mice is my standard work day
where I just sit down and type work
physically is usually i get i start
around nine o'clock in the morning and
then when the start when the Sun starts
to go down or which gets around
suppertime I'm done and somewhere in
between you know if I remember to eat
lunch you know oh you lunch or something
and then I got you know my regular
things I have got to do dirty they feed
my animals and my pets and go to the
grocery store when I have to and that's
an I go out a lot too I I try to get out
at night because I I get cabin fever
like on the parties and things like that
mm-hmm it's almost a function of who you
are it's not even work it sounds like
it's just kind of a function of what you
do every day you disagree yeah yeah yeah
I have a routine in the morning when you
get out of bed and you feed the pets and
shave and all that kind of thing
but um I used to work all that when you
know years ago I would work up a little
too three in the morning i just don't
like doing that anymore mmhmm yeah you
know I just believe it's important to
point out because so many people are
looking for the shortcuts like how do I
have this kind of success you know and
that and that put in the time not put in
the effort not put in the work so that's
why I was just curious to see with
everything you accomplished its kind of
hear you talking about but you gotta
remember I love doing it so they it's
not work it's like playing you're
getting paid for getting for playing is
what what it is and you know other
people do other things you know their
during their sports people what you know
athletes that's what they enjoy doing or
people who are businessmen ones who love
numbers you know and so if you can do
what you love to do this that's great
you're listening to film courage
we are speaking with author and
filmmaker Donald F glutes and on what
are some of the elements you tend to put
in all of your stories um chainsaws
wooden stakes silver bowl no uh I i put
dinosaur sit a lot of them i love i love
the old monster so i try to use as many
the old classic monster icon figures
vampires mummies werewolves
Frankenstein's monster that sort of
thing and i love dinosaurs and
superheroes and that sort of thing so um
a lot of my don't take too seriously
there's always a little bit of humor in
there somewhere you might have to read
between the lines or whatever but I I
tend to yeah I never thought of myself
as a comedy writer but a more and more
humor seems to keep creeping into some
of the things I do and how do you
structure your stories well I usually
when i'm doing a script i try to keep a
three-act structure i figure if my
scripts going to be let's say 100 pages
long so 30 some pages per act if I'm if
I'm up to page 37 or 38 and i'm still in
act 1 and I stop usually and go back and
start revising and I'm pretty
traditional in that sense and I've
written actually novels to using that
three act structure when I was writing
comic books it's a little bit different
when I was writing the horror comics and
they had a punch ending I would usually
try to think of the ending first and
then try to get a story to kind of lead
up to it the superhero stories were
different because they were mostly
continued and I was just thinking of
basic heroic plots you know villain
needs this to accomplish to grab to get
something with for with once he gets it
he'll can conquer the world the heroes
got to stop them and gets waylaid some
several times along the way that's a
pretty standard superhero apply how many
movies have have you directed all
together well feature-length live-action
we professionals have done six we know
cakes now and I did some others and some
documentary things and shorts and music
videos but as far as feature-length
movies with the beginning we know with
the plot and characters and everything
six and what has been the typical budget
range of these six films the most one we
ever had
was on our first that was about two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars okay
Dinosaur Valley Girls the least amount
of money I've ever had was 74,000 that
was for scarlet countess okay they
generally come in around 110 120
thousand dollars okay and they have all
I have all these your movies have they
reached the profits well not necessarily
for us not for us but other people we've
we've been up until now we've always had
other distributors who many of which
have ripped us off royally ninglin dying
Gus you don't get you know they we don't
know if the books are correct I mean
they made quite a bit of money off but
so we with the last film blood scarab we
decided to distribute ourselves inside
our own distribution wing of our company
and we're doing much much much better so
we're getting paid on a basically every
every few weeks we get money so of your
six films which are the ones did where
you say ripped off from you two should
do so would like you're purposely your
first four well like your first five or
worse five yeah verse five and we
finally learned the hard way you know we
were distributing ourselves now and now
people are coming us to distribute their
films which were thinking about we just
haven't gotten around to making a
decision yet have you put your own money
into the films and if not how did you
yeah the first film we did I actually
cook took a mortgage out of my house to
pay the the remaining $80,000 like we
couldn't raise the last film i need we
had a premiere date in chicago the music
box theatre to commit to that eight and
it was important to get a theatrical I
want to get a theatrical release because
once you get a theatrical release on
your low budget movie it's like getting
the stamp of approval on it it enhances
your other potential sales it makes more
people want to buy your DVD that's kind
of thing and but to commit to that date
and we had to commit to that date I did
no management was going to change them
maybe they wouldn't want our movie you
know in another year I had to get the
movie guarantee the movie would be
finished so I had to put all our
post-production costs on a credit card
my personal credit card
and so that wasn't really my money but
all the money that came in for like the
last couple years has been going to pay
this credit card off which had twenty
percent interest so the bill never went
down and luckily we found another
investor just a few weeks ago we paid
that off so now we're basically it a a
ground zero clean pick you know clear
playing field we don't worry about
paying it it's not this albatross
hanging over saying right sleep better
now yeah but i have put some money into
some of the old films and some i bother
my relatives and friends and do all
became investors and but to try not to
put your own money to if you can avoid
it mm-hmm and with your first five films
you know are these are these are they
have a broken even a night after has the
movie will come in or we don't know pay
off those early debts that you took on
we really don't know because we've had
so many distribution problems sometimes
you don't you get a statement and it's
got a tremendous amount of money on the
state now how much money you know maybe
its twenty thousand dollars a week at
three thousand dollars of it and then
they hold it back for two years we don't
even see it for three you know this is
the kind of things that we were dealing
with and nickel and diming us for you
know putting a label on the shrink-wrap
you know this is going to be another
three or four hundred bucks you know and
we find out what these things really
cost to put out and it's nowhere near
that so we have no idea how much is owed
us we actually took our first
distributor to court we sued him we won
the judgment but because we we found out
he's been selling it all over the world
and we actually saw some figures that
were very high we won the judgment and
then he said well okay take me a cart
well if we took him the court sodium
let's say he owed us thirty thousand
dollars and it cost us sixty thousand
dollars to go to court the train the
proof that he owed us 30 and then he had
the money so hidden that we weren't even
he got the 30 so what there was no point
in it so the thing is you learn your
lesson you don't give up you move on you
don't make the same mistake the next
time and I think we're finally we
haven't we're not making a mistake now
because we do have our own distribution
and doing all our films that we have
back now that we have the
fusion right store doing very well I
mean can we touch on that in terms of
you not now getting into your own
distribution company how did that how
did that come about and what does that
process been like well it was
recommended a friend of mine named
William Winkler who's also a director
producer who makes independent films and
did very well distributing his own films
explain the process to me you know most
people now by a retail buy things
through amazon and it's very easy to get
you your item on amazon you basically
need a barcode and it's easy to get a
bar code you can get a barcode when you
go to the replication plant they have
your dd's me manufacturers which we did
we got an amazon within about a week and
they you know they take a cut but you
still get most of the money yourself so
where and also you need but you'd still
need someone to represent you for
television and retail store most retail
stores unless you know the owner the
retail store and say hey will you take
my DVDs and so there you have to trust
somebody else but we we have two people
that we do trust and we've had
experience with in the past we're with
brutal releasing for television or tempe
entertainment for retail stores and so
but we have oliver we know we have all
the distribution for amazon for some of
the catalogs for selling on our website
that's all ours so now if we sell
something say through our website we get
one hundred percent of the money if we
sell through amazon we get like i don't
know sixty percent whatever it is when
we were going through the other
distributors because there were several
middlemen in between us and amazon we
might get ten percent twenty percent and
then take you forever to collect that
and maybe that's not even the correct
number so now we are in charge of our
own product every phase of it the
artwork everything we it's we're
responsible for and we know exactly
where every penny is going and when
everybody comes in with all of your film
how have you distribute the films in
terms of have all your films gone
theatrical have they go on the DVD have
they been on cable you know where
everywhere people seen your face well
they've done a television almost all of
them have been on TV we have a long run
with dinosaur valley girls
us a cable and we had a long run with
the Mummy's kiss the first mummys kiss
movie played two years on Cinemax almost
every week we've also been a
pay-per-view we always think though you
know that's always it's always an extra
bonus that we got a television sale or
foreign sale uh we usually think of them
as going directly to video or DVD but
with the last one we did this limited
theatrical release which was good and
now retro actively we got um several of
our other movies limited theatrical
releases and again each one now has that
sample of approval and you know you have
24 wall the theater you're not going to
nobody's gonna know major theaters are
going to take a low-budget film anymore
you have to basically rent the theater
yourself because when people go into a
movie theater and they're spending ten
or twelve dollars just to walk through
the door forgetting about parking and
popcorn if you got a date or a family or
something whatever it cost you a fortune
go see a movie people don't want to see
a low-budget film they want to get their
money's worth so you've got to have the
zillion explosions and Brad Pitt or
somebody has to be in it and it's got
you know it's got all the CGI effects so
they're going to see blockbuster movies
and so we can't compete with that so
we're doing the 40 wall thing where you
rent the theater and then you you split
the box office with the theater owner so
I'm at how many theaters would you for
wall and how have you targeted those
theaters you know well we've only done a
few theaters at this point but we you
you target theaters that have you know
people that go to those Cedars go to see
cult Frankenstein fantastic monsters of
the movies magazines that used to run
little photographs a little write-ups
about me so people know who I am and you
know it just it's just kind of a word of
mouth but we are going to finally start
advertising and see how that goes you
know taking full page ad out somewhere
ok that's what's going to ask so where
we are where are you looking at vert
eyes well there's a number of magazines
that specialize in videos and DVDs and
we have decided which one yet we've been
sort of waiting because it costs you the
same to put out an ad with one movie
shown you know
vert eyes as for so we've been waiting
till we head off for these dvds that we
had the rights back to and we and the
latest one which was the reissue of
dinosaur valley girl just came out a
couple weeks ago in fact it's not
officially out til november 25th so we
wanted to make it cost-effective on our
part by having all four of those movies
on there and have you have you gone
after the film festivals at all have you
looked in today me I'll get these genre
film film festivals film festivals are
usually to show your films and win
awards and things and we don't care
about winning awards we care about
making the money and and in sometimes
you've got to pay to be in the film
festival so it's not cost-effective for
us you know I read an interview um you
did with a slight I think called the
video graveyard and you were asked what
advice do you have for the young
filmmaker and I think you said something
like move out to California or Southern
California where all the real movie
action takes place and don't look at
filmmaking as a hobby or a second job
it's your day job plain and simple
correct can you expand on that well I I
grew up in Chicago which is not a city
that's really a city of it it's not
really conducive for creative people I
think you know because it's a it's the
hog butcher for the world that's you
know people in Chicago most people I
know to this day they seem to be
interested in two things their kids and
the Cubs ball team that's it that's what
they talk about and they can't we in the
end the people i know there that are
making films I don't people make
feature-length movies in Chicago and it
takes in two years to make a movie
because they all have day jobs they work
on weekends they wait until everybody's
available that weekend they don't pay
anybody sometimes uh the actors get this
gruntled and they leave so they got to
rewrite the part because they've already
shot to you know 20 minutes of film with
that person they're going to make it
another character then these are the
things and they don't look at it is real
work I mean my family most of the people
my family look at me is the black sheep
because I'm the one in the family
without the job the real job you know
and they just don't understand that you
can make your living off of what
so Campbell's call following your bliss
you know something that you really love
to do and have fun and you've got a I
whenever I used to go back there to
Chicago I would run into people that
would say hey I'm a special effects guy
or something or I I'd like you you know
could you consider me in your next time
I said well why would I bring somebody
out from Chicago probably at my expense
who may not even get there the plane
could get hijacked or something when I
can walk down my street and get anybody
I get my whole crew you know just in my
neighborhood because this is where
everybody lives if you're serious about
getting in this business this is where
you've got to live if you're serious
about making cars you move the Detroit
the same sort of thing and it to me if
they aren't ready to make that willing
to make that commitment they're not
really serious about it it's a hobby to
them and you not only you have to take
treaters the day job but you gotta be
able to star for a while you got to be
able to tighten the belt you've got to
be able to take risks you know where
you're not going to have a lot of money
coming in for for you know steady money
you and you can't give up because
there'll be a lot of discouragement up
front and you can never give up John
Landis who's you know big-time director
told me once he said what really
separates the men from the boys is in
this business is everybody gets ripped
off at the beginning people get the
Scourge or they fail what separates the
professionals from the amateurs and the
wannabes the professional is the person
that puts that all behind them moves on
and lets it lets the experience roll off
their back and you've got to be able to
do that if you have to be very thick
skin and you have to be able to accept
rejection you can't let rejection get
you all bummed out and shattered and
depressed anything because you can be
rejected for all kinds of strange things
they have nothing to do with your
ability your self-worth your talent you
know these are tell me is a writer when
you send your manuscripts out make sure
they come in on it to the office that
you're sending them to on the Tuesday or
Thursday because if it came in on a
Monday the person had just come back
from a week
again and they've probably tired there's
a huge stack that's piled up since
saturday or since the other friday and
then that time to look at your stuff and
give it the full you know the full value
of their attention if it comes in on a
friday they're thinking about going home
and relaxing and so you try to get it to
come in that little time but you know i
rejected actors because they look too
much like actors that are already in the
cast or maybe the leading lady is two
feet taller than the leading man or they
both have red hair you're crazy things
like this or they remind you of the
girlfriend you had an argument with that
morning you know and so you've got it
you know move on you get rejected you
move on to the next thing you know I
love everything you're touching my hair
Donald I absolutely love it now now you
have had a life of you know and you took
kind of test on this you've had a life
of living out your boyhood dreams which
is a phenomenal think and you're just
still doing it yeah about how does that
feel well it's great it's like it's like
like like playing and getting paid for
it and it it sort of keeps you younger
in your attitudes and everything you
know it keeps you healthier I think
physically mentally I mean I some of my
contemporaries we had a high school
reunion a year ago and the first person
that came in came in on a walker you
know I said well what's it and everybody
hated their jobs and they they were
retiring and they you know so they could
sit on the front porch and watch the
flowers girl you know and I can't do
that I i wanna i want to die in the
Santa lo am I don't you know I'm gonna
want to work till I drop I mean because
I love what I do besides working with
some bad distributors is there anything
you would have done differently that you
can give advice to people that haven't
don't yet probably what I would have
done he even though I was bitten by that
rock and roll bug I probably should have
not been so bitter against school and my
faculty and immediately pursued the
movie business like my contemporaries
did who all became very a lot of them
became very prominent people Randal
Kleiser
John Milius the guy he made all those
space movies you know so I should have
probably have pursued it then instead of
getting a start like 20 years later and
because it really is a young person's
business and we you know there's class
action suits that some of the unions
have against the industry about ageism
and people being you know after 35 years
old can't get in the studio studio job
and it's absolutely true so start when
you're young if you can that's if that's
your best chance of really getting in
the business if you want to work for the
studio system I'm lucky because I'm my
own boss and because I'm the producer
but I'm still making low-budget movies
I'm not make my hundred million dollar
movies and they still gotta raise the
money myself we own we just had a phone
call come in but they hung up and I
wasn't able to you know it's hard
because if we take phone calls here live
on the air has to just come at the right
moment so whoever is trying to reach us
if you do have a question for for Donald
glute you can try again the call we'll
see we get on the air you can also send
them a message to Twitter and anyone has
any questions for a for Donald yeah at
foam courage I want to make sure that
anyone listening if they want to find
your work Donald where were the places
we can go to find your films and in your
books and everything um well if you go
to my website which is Donald left lucam
there's pretty much links to everything
that's available now where you can buy
them hmm if you want to buy our movies
um we have a website from frontline
films com okay she has a shopping
gallery on there you can also get get
them on Amazon Amazon is pretty much
everything I've done it stolen in print
love it I love it and then you know and
then keep in mind i'm probably gonna say
this again but it's Donald F glute but
it spelled GL UT you have any any final
words you know it you know we're coming
down to our last few minutes here you
have some some more thoughts in terms of
what you put you've been discussing here
in the air as well I just you know I
just see i see so much talent go to
waste because people don't pursue their
talents and their dreams and you know
they take the easy way out they get a
job in your father's shoe store and they
stay there work
for the next 40 years you know if you
have a talent of something whether it's
writing art acting sports business or
whatever you should really my
recommendation is that you pursue that
and give it your best shot don't and
don't you know don't worry if it if it
doesn't happen immediately give it some
time sometimes it takes many many years
for these things they actually bear
fruit you know but if you if you if you
look at it professionally any you do
have the ability and you don't give up
don't give up it can't happen you can be
successful pretty much anything you want
to do but always remember get out there
and network meet people don't pass up
opportunities that come your way you
know because you never know who you're
going to meet you know who you're not
going to need to stay home mm-hmm and
when we should mention that you have
accidents peaking engagement this
afternoon for those leading in Los
Angeles any actors out there I'm going
to be speaking at two o'clock at a
seminar for actors and giving a lot of
good solid practical tough love looking
the I straight forward advice about
getting work in the business it's at the
Hammond theatre complex on santa monica
boulevard in hollywood right off of
cahuenga it's I think it's like 6400
something Santa Monica but I it's
upstairs just ask somebody out there
with there's always people standing out
there reading lines and trying to
memorize it because there's what it's a
big theater group up there and just come
up and say you're a guest of thon glute
knowledge in Austin ace thank you
awesome we've been speaking with author
and film director Donald F glute thank
you for sharing your story your
experience your insights thanks for
having at thank you I'm here with us
today if you if you haven't gone yet
please visit Donald F woot.com and once
again that's Bell GL UT thanks for
listening to this edition of film
courage have a great week